Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is therestishistory.com. Time to drive away from the grind and unwind in your new 2025 Mitsubishi Eclipse Cross. from the grind and unwind in your new 2025 Mitsubishi Eclipse Cross. No phones, no signal, no meetings. Just the smell of adventure. Lease the Eclipse Cross today for the equivalent of $89 weekly at 3.99% for 36 months. Plus, get a no charge, two-year maintenance package. Visit your local Mitsubishi dealer today or see mitsubishimotors.ca for details. Conditions apply. What's better than a well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue?
感谢收听《历史的剩余》。想要收听每周独家加更节目、无广告音频、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区，请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。是时候摆脱日复一日的枯燥生活，驾驶全新 2025 款三菱 Eclipse Cross 放松身心了。摆脱枯燥的生活，驾驶全新 2025 款三菱 Eclipse Cross 放松身心。没有手机，没有信号，没有会议。只有冒险的气息。今天就租用 Eclipse Cross，每周仅需 89 加元（相当于），3.99% 利率，期限 36 个月。此外，还可享受免费的两年保养套餐。立即访问您当地的三菱经销商，或访问 mitsubishimotors.ca 了解详情。条件适用。还有什么比在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理分明的肋眼牛排更好的呢？
A well-marbled ribeye sizzling on the barbecue that was carefully selected by an Instacart shopper and delivered to your door. A well-marbled ribeye you ordered without even leaving the kiddie pool. Whatever groceries your summer calls for, Instacart has you covered. Download the Instacart app and enjoy $0 delivery fees on your first three orders. Service fees, exclusions and terms apply. Instacart, groceries that over-deliver. All over the field, Roman soldiers lay dead in their thousands, horse and foot mingled, as the shifting phases of the battle or the attempt to escape had brought them together. Here and there wounded men, covered with blood, who had been roused to consciousness by the morning cold, were
有一块精心挑选并由 Instacart 采购员送到您家门口的、在烧烤架上滋滋作响、纹理分明的肋眼牛排。一块甚至不用离开幼儿戏水池就能下单的肋眼牛排。无论您的夏天需要什么杂货，Instacart 都能满足您的需求。下载 Instacart 应用程序，前三笔订单即可享受 0 美元配送费。服务费、排除条款和条款适用。Instacart，超值配送的杂货。放眼望去，战场上横尸遍野，成千上万的罗马士兵倒在血泊中，骑兵和步兵混杂在一起，因为战局的不断变化或逃跑的尝试将他们聚在了一起。稀稀落落地，一些浑身是血的伤员，被清晨的寒意惊醒恢复了意识，
dispatched by a quick blow as they struggled to rise from amongst the corpses. Others were found still alive, with the sinews in their thighs and behind their knees sliced through, baring their throats and necks and begging who would to spill what little blood they had left. Some had their heads buried in the ground, having apparently dug themselves holes and by smothering their faces with earth had choked themselves to death. Most strange of all was a Numidian soldier, still living and lying with nose and ears horribly lacerated, underneath the body of a Roman, who when his useless hands
在他们挣扎着从尸体堆中站起来时，被迅速的一击了结了。人们还发现其他人仍然活着，他们大腿和膝盖后面的肌腱被割断，暴露出喉咙和颈部，乞求任何路过的人放掉他们体内仅存的一点血。有些人的头埋在泥土里，显然是自己挖了洞，通过用泥土捂住脸而窒息身亡。最奇怪的是一个努米底亚士兵，他仍然活着，躺在一个罗马士兵的尸体下，鼻子和耳朵被可怕地撕裂，当他无用的双手
had no longer been able to grasp his sword, had died in the act of tearing his enemy in bestial fury with his teeth." So that was the account of the battlefield of Cannae by Livy and he's describing the morning after one of the bloodiest and most notorious days in the entire history, not just of Rome or of the Punic Wars, but of armed conflict generally, because this is one of the most studied, most discussed, most famous battles in all world history. It took place on the 2nd of August 216 BC and Tom, for the Romans this was the darkest day in all their history, wasn't it? It was. And for as long as their empire endured, Roman historians who wanted to emphasize some
再也无法握住宝剑时，他在以野兽般的愤怒用牙齿撕咬敌人的过程中死去了。”这是李维对坎尼战场的描述，他所描述的是整个历史上最血腥、最恶名昭着的日子之一的第二天清晨，这不仅是罗马或布匿战争的历史，也是所有武装冲突史上的历史，因为这是世界历史上被研究最多、讨论最多、最著名的战役之一。它发生于公元前 216 年 8 月 2 日，汤姆，对罗马人来说，这是他们历史上最黑暗的一天，不是吗？确实如此。而且只要他们的帝国存在，那些想要强调某些
particular shattering defeat would say, oh, this was the worst day ever, except for Cannae. And they would always acknowledge that even the worst defeat wasn't as terrible as Cannae had been. And I think what is fascinating is that modern historians as well have been kind of equally fascinated by the scale of the slaughter that was inflicted on Rome on that terrible day. So there are two really excellent studies of this battle, one by Greg Daly, Cannae, the experience of battle in the Second Punic War. He writes, very striking fact that there were more Romans and Italians killed in one day of fighting at Cannae than Americans killed in combat during the whole Vietnam War.
格外惨烈的失败的罗马历史学家就会说，哦，这是有史以来最糟糕的一天，除了坎尼。他们总是会承认，即使是最糟糕的失败也没有坎尼那么可怕。我认为迷人的是，现代历史学家同样对那场可怕日子里降临到罗马身上的屠杀规模着迷。因此，关于这场战役有两个非常优秀的专门研究，一本是格雷格·戴利（Greg Daly）的《坎尼：第二次布匿战争中的战斗体验》。他写道：一个非常惊人的事实是，在坎尼战役中一天内阵亡的罗马人和意大利人，比越战全美军在战斗中阵亡的人数还要多。
Wow. Yeah, that's a good fact. I mean, that's an amazing stat. And then Adrian Goldsworthy, who is essentially what my brother is to the Second World War, he is to the Roman army. I mean, he is the goat on this. And he wrote an excellent book on Cannae as well. And it has an introduction from Richard Holmes, you know, the great military historian. And Richard Holmes writes, the Romans lost more men killed in the British army on the first day of the Somme in 1916, which I guess for British people is always the kind of, it's the
哇。是的，这是一个很好的事实。我的意思是，这是一个惊人的统计数据。然后是阿德里安·戈德斯沃西（Adrian Goldsworthy），他基本上就像我兄弟对第二次世界大战那样，他就是罗马军队的专家。我的意思是，他是这方面的权威。他也写了一本关于坎尼的优秀书籍。并且有理查德·霍姆斯（Richard Holmes）的序言，你知道的，伟大的军事历史学家。理查德·霍姆斯写道，罗马人在1916年索姆河战役的第一天阵亡的英国士兵人数更多，我想对英国人来说，这总是那种，它是
measuring stick of pointless slaughter isn't it? But of course those are Vietnam and the First World War both industrialized conflicts, so the idea that a battle in the ancient world could have a scale of slaughter to rank alongside the conflicts of the modern age just seems extraordinary. But it's not the only reason why Canis is such a famous battle, is it? It's also famous because, you know, for people who are great students of military tactics, this is like sort of Maradona's second goal against England in 1986 or one of Lionel Messi's great performances in Roger Federer or something. It is the acme of perfection. Yeah, exactly. It is the absolute archetype of a vastly outnumbered force annihilating
衡量无意义屠杀的标准，不是吗？但当然，越南战争和第一次世界大战都是工业化冲突，所以古代世界的一场战役其屠杀规模竟能与现代冲突相媲美，这似乎非同寻常。但这并不是坎尼成为如此著名的战役的唯一原因，对吧？它也很有名，因为，你知道的，对于军事战术的狂热研究者来说，这就像是1986年马拉多纳对英格兰的第二个进球，或者是莱昂内尔·梅西在罗杰·费德勒面前的伟大表现之类的东西。它是完美的巅峰。是的，完全正确。它是以寡敌众并歼灭
a much superior one. And it's for that reason, I think, as Greg Daly puts it in his book, that can I may be the most studied battle in history. Because obviously, if you can distill the elixir, work out the formula that Hannibal applied, then hopefully you can apply that to your own age and win similarly stunning victories. And I mean, you'll know this Dominic as a student historian of the first world war, that first world war generals and strategists were obsessed by Cannae. So Schlieffen is the kind of the famous example that he was the chief of the German general staff, wasn't he? Kind of before the First World War devised this Schlieffen plan, or did he? I mean, I know it's very controversial, but
优势敌军的绝对原型。我认为正是出于这个原因，正如格雷格·戴利在他的书中所说，坎尼可能是历史上被研究最多的战役。因为很明显，如果你能提炼出这杯灵药，找出汉尼拔应用的公式，那么希望你就能将其应用到你自己的时代，并赢得同样惊人的胜利。我的意思是，作为第一次世界大战的历史学生，你肯定知道这一点，一战的将军和战略家们对坎尼着迷不已。因此，施里芬就是一个著名的例子，他是德国总参谋部参谋长，对吧？在第一次世界大战之前制定了这个施里芬计划，还是他制定的？我的意思是，我知道这很有争议，但
essentially the German high command were aiming at a battle of annihilation that was consciously inspired by what Hannibal had done. And after the war, there was a collection of his essays published that just had the title Cannae. And then in the Second World War, on the Eastern Front, again, lots of Hitler's generals were obsessed with replicating Hannibal's tactics. So Guderian in particular, with his tanks warring across the Eastern Front.
基本上德国最高指挥部旨在发动一场歼灭战，这场歼灭战是有意识地受汉尼拔所作所为启发的。战后，出版了一本他的论文集，书名就叫《坎尼》。然后在第二次世界大战中，在东线战场，希特勒的许多将军同样着迷于复制汉尼拔的战术。尤其是古德里安，他的坦克在东线横冲直撞。
He was very inspired by the example of the Carthaginian cavalry at Cannae. And weirdly, Americans with German names were also obsessed. So Eisenhower was obsessed by it. And more recently, Norman Schwarzkopf, who commanded the American forces in Desert Storm. He was always going on about how his tactics and strategy there were modeled on Hannibal. It's the kind of thing that I imagine that if I was to study at West Point, a man in a bow tie would talk about this battle for weeks.
他深受坎尼战役中迦太基骑兵例子的启发。奇怪的是，有着德国名字的美国人也同样着迷。所以艾森豪威尔对此着迷。最近的则是指挥沙漠风暴美军的诺曼·施瓦茨科普夫。他总是喋喋不休地谈论他在那里的战术和战略是如何以汉尼拔为原型的。这就像那种我想象如果我在西点军校学习，一个戴领结的人会连续几个星期谈论这场战役的事。
Firstly, talk about Thucydides. And then they'd have you as a guest lecturer or something, Tom. It'd be awful. It'd be soul destroying. Oh, what for the listeners or for me? No, I mean, you'd be handsomely remunerated. But I, as the student, I'd first have to endure the lecture by the man in the bow tie and then you'd pitching up to give an hour long lecture and my life would be in ruins. Anyway, let's move on. This is an amazing subject because the thing is that there is a risk with viewing can I
首先，谈论修昔底德。然后他们会请你作为客座讲师什么的，汤姆。那太糟糕了。那将是毁灭灵魂的。哦，是对听众还是对我？不，我的意思是，你会得到丰厚的报酬。但我，作为学生，我首先得忍受戴领结的人的演讲，然后你登台发表一个小时的演讲，我的生活就会毁于一旦。不管怎样，我们继续吧。这是一个令人惊叹的主题，因为问题在于，将坎尼视为
as a kind of platonic ideal of a battle. Because if you abstract it, you get away from what actually makes the study of this battle, of maybe all the battles in ancient history, so compelling and so unsettling and actually terrifying. Because what both Daly and Goldsworthy do in their two actually quite different books, but in one thing they're very similar, they really emphasize the physicality of warfare generally, but specifically in this battle. And it reminds us that Cannae is a battle that is fought in the context of the much broader war that we've been talking about in this series between distinctive commanders, between distinctive armies, cities, ways of life. And the ancient
一种战役的柏拉图式理想存在着风险。因为如果你把它抽象化，你就会远离真正使这场战役的研究（或许是古代历史中所有战役的研究）如此引人入胜、令人不安甚至实际上感到恐怖的原因。因为戴利和戈德斯沃西在他们两本实际上截然不同但又有一点非常相似的书中所做的，就是他们真正强调了战争普遍的物质性，尤其是这场战役中的物质性。它提醒我们，坎尼这场战役是在我们在这个系列中一直在谈论的更广泛的战争背景下进行的，它发生在杰出的指挥官、杰出的军队、城市和生活方式之间。而古代
sources and you quoted Livy, but we have Polybius as well, we have Plutarch, they are unusually visceral in their accounts of what actually happens when these, you know, the Roman and the Carthaginian way of war comes up against each other in this great titanic clash, and they evoke the dust, the stench, the terror, the horror, which even the victors on the day after the battle are kind of struck dumb by it. And I think that it's possible to evoke and make vivid, in a way that is not true about other battles in antiquity, something of the lived experience of those who fought in it. So that's why it's so interesting. So we can immerse ourselves in a way that we can't with other battles. We can immerse ourselves in what it was like to be there.
史料（你引用了李维，但我们也有波利比乌斯，我们还有普鲁塔克），他们在描述当罗马和迦太基的战争方式在这场巨大的泰坦式冲突中发生碰撞时实际发生了什么时，其描述异常生动逼真，他们唤起了尘土、恶臭、恐惧、惊骇，以至于连战后第二天的胜利者都被这一切惊得说不出话来。我认为，以一种古代其他战役所不具备的方式来唤起和生动展现那些参战者的真实体验是可能的。这就是为什么它如此有趣。因此，我们可以以一种无法在其他战役中做到的方式让自己沉浸其中。我们可以让自己沉浸在身临其境的感觉中。
So before we get into the sort of the total immersion as it were, let's give ourselves a little bit of context. So Hannibal, let's just remember, had invaded Italy in autumn 218, this amazing journey across the Alps with his elephants that took two weeks, then down into the Valley of the Po, he had defeated a combined Roman army at the river Trebia. Then six months or so later, the summer of 217, he had ambushed an entire Roman army near Lake Trasimene, that's seen in the defile when all his men are up on the heights and they come pouring down. And they'd killed the consul who was commanding the Pete Hegseth of the Roman Republic, if you remember. He's been roaming around southern
所以在我们进入那种完全沉浸式体验之前，让我们先了解一下背景。所以，汉尼拔，让我们记住，在公元前 218 年的秋天入侵了意大利，他带着大象穿越阿尔卑斯山的这段神奇旅程花了两个星期，然后进入波河谷，他在特雷比亚河击败了一支联合的罗马军队。大约六个月后，即公元前217年夏天，他在特拉西梅内湖附近伏击了整整一支罗马军队，这就是那个狭窄隘口的场景，当时他所有的部下都在高处，然后倾巢而出。正如你所记得的那样，他们杀死了指挥罗马共和国皮特·海格塞斯（Pete Hegseth）的执政官。他一直在意大利南部漫游，
Italy, around Campania, the Roman breadbasket, torching the estates of the Roman nobility. Since then, he has been on the eastern flank of Rome in Apulia. It's basically R&R for his men. They've been recharging their batteries, haven't they? Yeah. So at this point, Tom, what does Hannibal want to do? What's his plan? To take the city of Rome to destroy the Roman Republic? No, that's too ambitious for him. So what does he think he's going to plausibly do? I think that the Romans assume that his ambition is to wipe out Rome, but I think that they're
围绕着罗马的粮仓坎帕尼亚，烧毁罗马贵族的庄园。自那以后，他一直在罗马东翼的普利亚。这基本上就是他部下的休闲放松。他们一直在充电，不是吗？是的。那么在这一点上，汤姆，汉尼拔想做什么？他的计划是什么？攻占罗马城以消灭罗马共和国？不，这对他来说太野心勃勃了。那么他认为自己实际上能做什么呢？我认为罗马人假设他的野心是消灭罗马，但我认为他们
projecting their own assumptions onto Hannibal there. I don't think Hannibal, well we know this because later he signs treaties say with the King of Macedon and he specifies what Rome's role will be in this. He's not saying that Rome is going to be wiped out. What he wants essentially is to destroy the alliance system in Italy that upholds Roman power and it upholds it because it provides Rome with men. The whole way through the series we've been talking, this is the key to Roman power and Hannibal recognizes that and his strategy is to try and kneecap Rome's prestige. And he wants to do that essentially by looting and pillaging
是将他们自己的假设投射到了汉尼拔身上。我不认为汉尼拔——好吧，我们知道这一点，因为后来他与马其顿国王签订了条约，并明确了罗马在其中的角色。他并没有说罗马将被消灭。他的基本意图是摧毁意大利境内支撑罗马权力的联盟体系，这个体系支撑着罗马，因为它为罗马提供了士兵。贯穿整个系列节目，我们一直在讨论，这是罗马力量的关键，汉尼拔认识到了这一点，他的战略是试图削弱罗马的威望。他主要通过掠夺和劫掠
her lands to demonstrate to everybody that the Romans can no longer defend their own lands. But above all, he wants to annihilate her armies repeatedly in battle so that in the long run, the Romans will be forced to sue for terms because this is what people do in antiquity. The Carthaginians have been fighting wars for centuries and centuries. It's never been a war of total annihilation. It's always been about forcing your enemy to sue for terms and then you arrive at a kind of compromise and everyone gets on with their lives. It's very Roman to assume that it's all or nothing. And this I think ultimately is what Hannibal doesn't understand. Perhaps he comes to the understanding of it over the course of his time in Italy. But at this point, he still
罗马的土地来实现这一点，向所有人证明罗马人再也无法保卫自己的土地了。但最重要的是，他希望在战斗中反复歼灭罗马的军队，以便从长远来看，罗马人将被迫求和，因为这就是古代人们的做法。迦太基人已经打了几个世纪的仗。这从来都不是一场彻底歼灭的战争。这总是关于迫使敌人求和，然后达成某种妥协，大家继续过各自的生活。认为这是一场非黑即白的全面战争是非常“罗马式”的想法。我认为这最终就是汉尼拔所不理解的。也许他在意大利期间逐渐意识到了这一点。但在这一点上，他仍然
thinks if he can only force the ultimate climactic battle, then he will be able to get the Italians to cast off their loyalty to Rome, to come over to him, and the Romans will be forced to sue for terms. And of course, this requires him to tread very delicately on Italian toes. So that's one of the reasons why over the course of the winter he moves camp so he doesn't outstay his welcome. And it's why in the course of the summer of 218, he moves to a specifically Roman depot, a Roman entrepot full of stores and arms, which is called Cannae. And he captures this town, all the kind of the material, the weapons, the provender, the produce that are stored there are now Hannibal's. It enables him to cut across Roman supply lines. It prompts the local Italians to start wavering in their
认为只要他能强行发动最终的决战，他就能让意大利人抛弃对罗马的忠诚，投靠他，而罗马人将被迫求和。当然，这就要求他在踩意大利人的脚趾时非常小心翼翼。这也是为什么在冬天他要转移营地以免招致厌烦的原因之一。这也是为什么在公元前 218 年夏天，他转移到一个专门的罗马仓库，一个储藏着物资和武器的罗马贸易站，名叫坎尼。他攻占了这座城镇，所有储存在那里的物资、武器、粮草和农产品现在都归汉尼拔所有。这使他能够切断罗马的补给线，促使当地的意大利人开始动摇对
loyalty to Rome, which is everything that Hannibal wants. But also there is an additional advantage to it, which is that although Cannae stands on a slight ridge of hills, all around it, the land, and this is quite unusual for Italy, is completely flat. And because it's flat, this makes it perfect for cavalry. Cavalry is in many ways Hannibal's strongest arm, and it's the Romans weakest arm. And so he's hoping, I think, to offer himself and his army as bait and Cannae is the hook. So he wants to lure them into another battle, another pitch battle, because basically he
罗马的忠诚，这就是汉尼拔所渴望的一切。但除此之外，还有一个额外的好处，那就是尽管坎尼坐落在一个小山脊上，但它周围的土地（这在意大利相当罕见）完全是平坦的。正因为它是平坦的，这使得它非常适合骑兵作战。骑兵在许多方面是汉尼拔最强的兵种，而它是罗马人最弱的兵种。因此，他希望（我认为）将自己和他的军队作为诱饵，而坎尼就是鱼钩。所以他想把他们引诱到另一场战斗中，另一场阵地战中，因为基本上他
thinks he's unbeatable in pitch battles, do you think? I think he's backing himself, I think, you know, backing himself all the way. But he, you know, also he recognizes it's the only way he has any prospect of winning. I mean, he's right in that. He just has to beat them again and again and again and again. All right. So what about the Romans? Are they going to take this trap? Because if you remember from last time, Fabius Maximus, who had been serving as dictator, he'd been appointed for six months as sort of supreme magistrate, the man who makes the decisions in command of the Republic. He has been actually shying away from battle. I mean, his whole
认为自己在阵地战中是不可战胜的，你觉得呢？我认为他对自己充满信心，我认为，你知道的，一路对自己信心满满。但他也认识到这是他获胜的唯一可能方式。我的意思是，在这点上他是对的。他必须一次又一次、一次又一次地击败他们。好吧。那么罗马人呢？他们会落入这个陷阱吗？因为如果你还记得上次的内容，费边·马克西姆斯（Fabius Maximus）曾担任独裁官，他被任命为六个月的最高长官，即指挥共和国做出决定的那个人。他实际上一直在回避战斗。我的意思是，他的全部
strategy has been wait and see, play the long game. Delaying. The Fabian strategy, right. You said last time that a lot of the Romans don't like this. They think it's un-Roman, they're losing patience. So have they now definitively run out of patience by the time Hannibal sets up his base at Cannae? Well, I think we said in the last episode, Fabius's strategy, you know, it's not a long term one. It's all about giving the Republic time to recruit and to train and to arm enough men to provide an army that will be so overwhelming that Hannibal will be powerless to defeat
战略一直是等待观望，打持久战。拖延。费边战略，对吧。你上次说过，许多罗马人不喜欢这样。他们认为这不符合罗马作风，他们正在失去耐心。那么，当汉尼拔在坎尼建立基地时，他们的耐心是否已经彻底耗尽了？好吧，我想我们在上一集里说过，费边的战略，你知道，这不是长期的。这一切都是为了给共和国时间去招募、训练和武装足够多的人员，以提供一支势不可挡的军队，让汉尼拔无力击败
it. And the emblem of the fact that the time of emergency is over and it's time to resume normal service and basically launch a war of destruction against the invader is the fact that when Fabius lays down his dictatorship, he's only dictator for six months, that's the legal restriction. There are new elections and two new consuls are elected and these consuls, certainly one of them has definitely been elected on a kind of let's defeat Hannibal and wipe him out in a battle ticket. And this is a guy called Gaius Terencius Varro. He is cast by both Polybius and Livy as being a bit like Flaminius, the guy who had lost the battle at Lake Trasimene. So he is cast as a kind of slightly magga figure. He's a novice homo,
它。而紧急状态已经结束、是时候恢复正常服务并基本上对入侵者发动毁灭之战的标志是，当费边卸任他的独裁官职务时（他只担任六个月的独裁官，这是法律限制），将会举行新的选举，并选出两位新的执政官，而这些执政官中，肯定有一人是凭借“让我们打败汉尼拔并在战斗中消灭他”的竞选纲领当选的。这个人名叫盖乌斯·特伦蒂乌斯·瓦罗（Gaius Terencius Varro）。无论是波利比乌斯还是李维，都把他塑造得有点像弗拉米尼乌斯（Flaminius），也就是在特拉西梅内湖战役中战败的那个人。因此，他被塑造为一个略微有些“让罗马再次伟大”（maga）的人物。他是一个新贵（novus homo），
so he's someone from outside the mainstream, outside the conventional political elites. And according to Livy, he's actually the son of a butcher, which I think is improbable, probably reflects Livy's snobbery about people who rise above their station because clearly Varro is a very able politician. He actually comes top of the whole roster of people who are campaigning to be consul that year. And it means that the guy who subsequently comes to be elected as his colleague, a guy called Lucius Imelius Paulus, although he's from a very distinguished political dynasty, so much more of a conventional consul, he can't really pull rank because Varro does
所以他是一个来自主流之外、传统政治精英之外的人。根据李维的说法，他实际上是一个屠夫的儿子，我认为这不太可能，这可能反映了李维对那些地位上升的人的势利眼，因为显然瓦罗是一个非常有能力的政治家。他在当年竞选执政官的所有候选人中实际上名列前茅。这意味着随后被选为他同僚的那个人，一个名叫卢基乌斯·埃米利乌斯·保卢斯（Lucius Aemilius Paulus）的人，尽管他来自一个非常显赫的政治家族，是一个更传统的执政官，但他不能真正压制瓦罗，因为瓦罗确实
have the kind of weight of electoral achievement behind him. And it's this that enables Polybius and Livy to cast Varro as the guy who's really responsible for the whole strategy. So Polybius in particular casts him as being rash, as being incompetent, as being headstrong. And in part, I think this is because clearly Varro was to a degree, I mean, as we will see, but it's also because Aemilius Paulus, the other consul, is the grandfather of Polybius' Roman patron.
有着选举胜利的分量作为后盾。正是这一点让波利比乌斯和李维得以将瓦罗塑造成对整个战略真正负责的人。因此，波利比乌斯特别将他塑造为鲁莽、无能和固执的人。部分原因，我认为是因为很明显瓦罗在某种程度上确实如此（正如我们将看到的），但这也是因为另一个执政官埃米利乌斯·保卢斯是波利比乌斯的罗马赞助人的祖父。
So Polybius isn't really going to diss Paulus, and Polybius is keen to spare powerless responsibility for this strategy. And Livy also plays it up casting powerless as a man who is very sensible, very balanced, very restrained. But I think that this is this is nonsense. So as with Trebia, I think that both consoles are absolutely set on forcing a battle because why else would they have raised their forces? Why else would they have marched against Hannibal? Why would they go against everything that is instinctual in the Roman cast of mind? And you know, the reasons that they are
所以波利比乌斯并不真的打算贬低保卢斯，而且波利比乌斯热衷于免除保卢斯对这一战略的责任。李维也借此大肆渲染，将保卢斯塑造成一个非常明智、非常平衡、非常克制的人。但我认为这纯粹是无稽之谈。因此，就像在特雷比亚一样，我认为两位执政官都绝对坚决要强行开战，因为如果不是这样，他们为什么要集结军队？他们为什么要进军对抗汉尼拔？他们为什么要违背罗马人心态中所有出于本能的东西？你知道，他们之所以
set on this course is because they think if they don't wipe out Hannibal, then it absolutely does threaten their hold on Italy. But also they feel it as a massive insult. You know, the Romans do not want to be disrespected. And also they know that if they defeat Hannibal, then that's it. Hannibal can't, you know, the Romans can survive endless defeats. Hannibal can't. One defeat for Hannibal and the war is over. So I think all of those reasons, you can see why they think that the Fabian strategy served its time, but now enough. Let's crack on. Let's do this. And they've had a long time to think about it. I mean, months and months have passed. They've had a long time to think about, okay, here is this guy with all his cavalry and
坚持这一路线，是因为他们认为如果不消灭汉尼拔，那么这绝对会威胁到他们对意大利的统治。但他们也将其视为一种巨大的侮辱。你知道的，罗马人不愿意被轻视。而且他们知道，如果他们击败了汉尼拔，那就大功告成了。汉尼拔无法（你知道，罗马人可以在无休止的失败中存活下来）。汉尼拔不能。汉尼拔只要遭遇一次失败，战争就结束了。所以出于所有这些原因，你可以看出为什么他们认为费边的战略已经完成了它的使命，但现在够了。让我们开干吧。让我们这么做。而且他们有很长的时间来考虑这个问题。我的意思是，几个月过去了。他们有很长的时间来考虑：好吧，这里有这个家伙和他的所有骑兵以及
whatnot, the Africans, the Gauls and stuff. How are we actually going to beat him? And Tom, have they dreamed up a new effective strategy? Well, we mentioned the Battle of the Somme and I know that there's kind of revisionist takes on British first world war generals, but I think there is a slight element of, you know, the conventional idea that, oh, that didn't work. Let's try it again only with more men. Right. Okay. That's basically what's happening. And the reason for that is because the ability to raise enormous numbers of men is what the Roman Republic is all about. And clearly it's
诸如此类的军队，非洲人、高卢人等等。我们究竟要怎么打败他呢？汤姆，他们有没有梦想出一个新的有效战略？嗯，我们提到了索姆河战役，我知道对英国一战将军有一些修正主义的看法，但我认为其中有一点点，你知道的，传统的想法，即“这没用，让我们再试一次，只是带更多的人”。对，好吧。这基本上就是正在发生的事情。而原因在于，能够招募大量士兵正是罗马共和国的全部意义所在。很明显，这是
something that Hannibal can't do. So the aim is to just raise an army that is so vast that there is no prospect of it possibly losing. So what they do is there are four legions already in the field. So there were the two legions that had been left in the field after late Trasimene under the command of the consul who hadn't been wiped out, which Fabius had then taken over and he had then recruited two further legions. So that's four legions and they have been sent off at the beginning of 218 to shadow Hannibal on the eastern side of the Apennines in Apulia. So they are already in situ. Paulus and Varro, the two new consuls, they then set about raising two new legions each,
汉尼拔无法做到的事情。因此，目标是组建一支如此庞大的军队，以至于它没有任何失败的可能。所以他们做的是，战场上已经有四个军团了。所以有两个军团在特拉西梅内湖战役后被留在战场上，由未被消灭的执政官指挥，费边随后接管了这些军团，然后他又招募了另外两个军团。所以那是四个军团，它们在公元前 218 年初就被派往普利亚亚平宁山脉东侧监视汉尼拔。所以它们已经在那里了。保卢斯和瓦罗，两位新执政官，他们随后着手每人招募两个新军团，
so another four in total, and they spend the early months of their consulship drilling them, training them, readying them for battle. Now these legions are much larger than normal. So each one consists of 5,000 infantry, 300 cavalry. They also recruit an equal number of men from the Italian allies. So mental maths, the total is about 80,000 infantry, 6,000 cavalry. I mean, 80,000 infantry, I mean, that is an enormous number of men. Yeah. By any standards, let's alone the standards of the ancient world. That's about twice the size of Villa Park. Oh my word, that's your standard.
总共又是四个，他们花了好几个月的时间对他们进行操练、训练，为战斗做准备。现在，这些军团比平时大得多。所以每个军团由 5,000 名步兵、300 名骑兵组成。他们还从意大利盟友中招募了相同数量的人员。所以用心算一下，总数大约是 80,000 名步兵，6,000 名骑兵。我的意思是，80,000 名步兵，我的意思是，这是一个极其庞大的数字。是的。无论按什么标准来看，更不用说古代的标准了。这大约是维拉公园球场（Villa Park）容量的两倍。哦天哪，这就是你的标准。
That is literally almost as many people as there are members of the Restless History Club. Yeah, that's a lot of people. Imagine them all being wiped out. That would be terrible. Yeah, awful. I mean, what a formidable force they would make. Let's be serious about it.
这几乎和“历史的剩余”俱乐部（Restless History Club）的成员一样多。是的，有很多人。想象一下他们全部被消灭。那将是可怕的。是的，太可怕了。我的意思是，他们将组成多么强大的力量啊。让我们严肃对待这件事。
This is now a force far bigger than anything Hannibal can command, right? So they have good grounds for thinking, you know, no matter what the tactics, our army is now so enormous. There's no way Hannibal can beat us. Yeah. And this sense that the whole city is now going to war is enhanced by the fact that about a third of the Senate are serving in the army. And this sense that the Roman elites justify their status by their readiness to fight is very, very manifest in the roster of people going to war with Hannibal in 216. Fabius doesn't go, but his erstwhile master of horse, Menesius Rufus, he goes, he's serving as a tribune. So are many others who have been consuls, so they have experience
这现在是一支远比汉尼拔所能指挥的任何力量都庞大的军队，对吧？所以他们有充分的理由认为，无论战术如何，我们的军队现在都如此庞大。汉尼拔绝无可能击败我们。是的。整个城市现在都要投入战争的这种感觉，由于大约三分之一的元老院元老都在军队中服役而得到了加强。而罗马精英们通过随时准备战斗来证明自己的地位这种感觉，在公元前 216 年随汉尼拔参战的人员名册中表现得非常、非常明显。费边没有去，但他曾经的骑兵长官梅内修斯·鲁弗斯（Menesius Rufus）去了，他以军团长（tribune）身份服役。许多担任过执政官的人也是如此，所以他们有指挥经验。
of command. They're all serving as tribunes who are essentially the kind of the link men between the two consuls who are in command and the mass of the legions. You know, it's not just about the vastness of the manpower. It's also about the seasoned experience of the commanding officers. And these officers, for the first time in Roman history, swear a formal oath of service, what's called a sacramentum. And Livy gives us the terms of it, never to leave the field in order to save their own skins, nor to abandon their place in the line for any purpose
他们都以军团长的身份服役，军团长基本上是身兼指挥官的两名执政官与庞大军团士兵之间的联络人。你知道的，这不仅关乎庞大的人力。这也关乎指挥官们的丰富经验。而这些军官在罗马历史上第一次宣誓效忠，即所谓的“圣誓”（sacramentum）。李维向我们提供了誓词的条款：绝不为了保全自己而离开战场，也绝不为了恢复或取回武器、打击敌人或拯救朋友以外的任何目的而放弃自己在阵列中的位置。这将为士兵们在未来几个世纪加入军团时所宣誓的誓词确立一个模板。
other than to recover or fetch a weapon, to strike an enemy, or to save a friend. And this will establish a template for the oath that soldiers are swearing when they join the legions for centuries to come. It's all about fostering a sense of common purpose that this really is the Roman people in arms, joined in a unity, in a kind of sense of determination that is shared by every class of person, by every age group. And I think this matters not just for psychological reasons, but also because there is a slight problem with the sheer scale of the army, which is that it's not at all integrated. I mean, none of these legions have kind of really served
这一切都是为了培养一种共同目标的意识，即这确实是拿起武器的罗马人民，他们团结一致，拥有各个阶层、各个年龄段所共有的坚定决心。我认为这不仅出于心理原因，还因为军队的绝对规模存在一个小问题，那就是它根本没有经过整合。我的意思是，这些军团中没有哪个真正互相并肩作战过。所以瓦罗和保卢斯，他们各自拥有自己的两个军团。然后你有那四个位于坎尼以北世纪的军团。这些军团都没有接受过训练，更不用说一起并肩作战了。其结果当然是，从某种意义上说，
with each other. So Varro and Powlis, they each have their own two legions. Then you've got the four legions that are on the century north of Cannae. None of these legions have trained or still less campaigned together. And the consequence of that, of course, is that in a sense, the very size of the army becomes a source of potential weakness as well as of strength because it's very ponderous, it's very muscle bound, it doesn't have the ability to do complicated maneuvers or anything like that. It can only do the most basic tactics and Hannibal knows this. You know, his spies will be out there, he will be computing and working it out.
军队的规模本身既成了潜在弱点的来源，也成了力量的来源，因为它非常笨重，尾大不掉，它不具备做复杂机动或诸如此类事情的能力。它只能执行最基础的战术，而汉尼拔深知这一点。你知道的，他的间谍会在外面，他会进行计算和摸索。
And I think that that's why you have this incredible scene in late July when at last the two consuls have joined the other four legions north of Cannae and then them advancing southwards towards Cannae where Hannibal's army is. And the Carthaginians, like the Spartans at Thermopylae seeing the Persians approach, they see great dust cloud kicking up and then the glint of metal and this army that is vast beyond their wildest imaginings and it's not surprising that a lot of the Carthaginians feel quite nervous and there's an anecdote that's recorded by Plutarch and there's one of Hannibal's officers, a guy named Gisco, expressed himself astonished by the numbers of the enemy.
我认为这就是为什么在 7 月下旬会出现这样一个不可思议的场景：两个执政官终于与坎尼以北的其他四个军团汇合，然后他们向南推进，朝汉尼拔军队所在的坎尼进发。而迦太基人就像在温泉关看到波斯人逼近的斯巴达人一样，他们看到巨大的尘埃滚滚升起，然后是金属的反光，这支军队庞大得超出了他们最疯狂的想象，难怪许多迦太基人感到相当紧张，普鲁塔克记录了一个轶事：汉尼拔的一位军官，一个名叫吉斯科（Gisco）的人，对敌人的数量表示惊讶。
Hannibal adopted a serious expression and said, Yes, Gisco, but you are overlooking an even more astonishing fact. And what is that? asked Gisco. Why? answered Hannibal. That in all that vast Roman army, there is no one called Gisco. And there is manly laughter. I actually genuinely don't get what he's talking about. What's his point? He's saying, okay, they have all these numbers, but they don't have
汉尼拔露出了严肃的表情，说道：“是的，吉斯科，但你忽视了一个更令人惊奇的事实。”“那是什么？”吉斯科问。“为什么？”汉尼拔回答说。“在那支庞大的罗马军队中，竟然没有一个人叫吉斯科。”然后是一阵男人们的笑话声。我其实真的不明白他在说什么。他的重点是什么？他是说，好吧，他们有这么多人，但他们没有
anyone, you know, they don't have people of your caliber, Gisco. I am surrounded by people like you. We have the winning of this. And I think that that anecdote kind of sums up what seems to have been the mood probably on both sides, which is a kind of mixture of nervousness and confidence of kind of hesitancy, but also a kind of relish for the big showdown, the World Cup final that is approaching. Everyone knows this is the big one. And I think that probably explains why battle isn't joined immediately. There's a certain degree of eyeballing. You know, it's the two heavyweight champions kind of standing on the weights and, you know, insulting each other and that kind of thing. So one will
任何人，你知道的，他们没有像你这样 caliber 的人，吉斯科。我周围都是像你这样的人。我们有获胜的把握。我认为这个轶事某种程度上概括了当时双方可能存在的心情，也就是一种紧张与自信交织的心情，一种犹豫不决，但也有一种对即将到来的重头戏（即将到来的世界杯决赛）的狂热。每个人都知道这是一场大战。我想这大概解释了为什么战斗没有立即打响。有一种对视的氛围。你知道的，这就像两个重量级拳王站在秤上互相侮辱之类的。所以一方会
draw up battle lines, but the other won't respond. Then the other will do it. They're kind of maneuvering this way and that. And Polybius and Livy, when they look back at this, they say, oh, well, this is because Paulus is in command one day and he doesn't want to fight and then Varro is the next day and he's eager to fight. I don't think that's true. I think it's it's reflective of you know the mixture of anticipation and nervousness that is characteristic on both sides. They're kind of tensing themselves up but it's perfectly clear there is going to be a battle because there's no way that either side can back down. And sure enough, Dominic, on the 2nd of August, 216, Dawn sees the Romans taking up positions to offer battle and Hannibal rides out to a ridge, looks at it, gives the signal to
摆出战斗阵型，但另一方不会回应。然后另一方会这样做。他们以这种或那种方式进行机动。波利比乌斯和李维在回溯这段历史时会说，哦，好吧，这是因为有一天保卢斯在指挥，他不想打仗，而第二天轮到瓦罗了，他渴望打仗。我不认为那是真的。我认为这反映了双方普遍存在的期待与紧张情绪的混合。他们正在为自己打气，但很明显必有一战，因为任何一方都无法退缩。果不其然，多米尼克，在公元前 216 年 8 月 2 日，
his men, his general staff who were around him, says, yeah, let's go for this. And it becomes clear to the Romans that Hannibal is going to accept their offer of battle. The battle of Cannae is about to begin. So I'm absolutely breathless with excitement. Come back after the break to find out what happens. It won't take long to tell you neutral's ingredients. what happens. It won't take long to tell you Neutral's ingredients. Vodka. Soda.
黎明时分，罗马人开始摆开阵势准备迎战，汉尼拔骑马来到一处山脊上，看了一眼，向身边的部下和总参谋部发出信号，说道：“行吧，我们上吧。”罗马人清楚地看到汉尼拔将接受他们的战书。坎尼战役即将开始。我兴奋得喘不过气来。休息一下，回来看看会发生什么。告诉你 Neutral 的配料花不了多长时间。发生什么。告诉你 Neutral 的成分花不了多长时间。伏特加。苏打水。
Natural flavours. So what should we talk about? No sugar added. Neutral. Refreshingly simple. Welcome back to the Rest is History. It is dawn on the 2nd of August, 216. I'm outside the tent of the Roman commander Varro, a red
天然风味。那么我们该聊点什么呢？无添加糖。Neutral。清爽简朴。欢迎回到《历史的剩余》。现在是公元前 216 年 8 月 2 日的黎明。我站在罗马指挥官瓦罗的帐篷外，一面红色的
flag has been hoisted, the signal Tom, that battle is about to begin. So paint the scene for us please. So the senior Roman officers have already met for their briefing and they've gone out to tell their men what the plan is. The two consuls, Pharaoh and Paulus have emerged from their headquarters and they are wearing the traditional scarlet cloak that a consul wears on a day of battle. So this is not the Trebia where Hannibal had bounced the Romans into fighting without having breakfast. This time the Romans have all breakfasted and then leaving camp, they've been able to take up position on ground
旗帜已经升起，汤姆，这是战斗即将开始的信号。请为我们描绘一下当时的场景吧。资深罗马军官已经开会进行了简报，并出去告诉他们的士兵计划是什么。两位执政官法罗（Pharaoh，此处指Varro）和保卢斯从他们的指挥部里走出来了，他们穿着执政官在作战日穿的传统猩红披风。所以这不同于特雷比亚战役，当时汉尼拔迫使罗马人在没有吃早饭的情况下仓促应战。这一次，罗马人们都吃过早饭，然后离开营地，能够在他们自己的将军选择的土地上占据阵型。
of their own generals choosing. Now it has always been a problem for us doing podcasts about battles. Firstly, that it's quite difficult to paint the scene on a podcast. And secondly, that sometimes we're not quite as interested in military dispositions as we should be. However, this for me is an exception because this is the one battle that I've been obsessed by since I was very young. And I had a book by brilliant writer and artist called Pete Connolly. And he wrote a series of what one on the Romans one on the Greek armies and then he wrote one called Hannibal and the enemies of Rome, which I still have it right next to me as I sit here and he did the illustrations for it as well as the writing the text. And his take was that, I'll set the scene, there is this very flat featureless plain, but there are two natural
在播客中谈论战役对我们来说一直是个难题。首先，在播客中描绘场景非常困难。其次，有时我们对军事部署的兴趣并不像我们应该的那样大。然而，对我来说这是一个例外，因为这是自我很小的时候起就一直让我着迷的一场战役。我有一本书，作者是一位才华横溢的作家兼艺术家，名叫皮特·康诺利（Pete Connolly）。他写了一系列书籍，一本关于罗马人，一本关于希腊军队，然后他写了一本名为《汉尼拔与罗马的敌人》，我坐在这里时，它就放在我旁边，而且不仅文字是他写的，插图也是他画的。他的看法是（我来设定场景）：这里有一片非常平坦、没有任何地标的平原，但有两个自然
features that determined where Connolly thinks the battle was fought. The first of these is a very winding river called the Alphidius, the course of which has changed over the course of time, but Connolly argues that it was about one and a half miles from a ridge of hills and Cannae sits on this ridge of hills. And so you have this stretch of open ground between the hills and the river Alphidius and to quote Goldsworthy who buys into Connolly's take on this, the advantages of this position are obvious. The Romans were able to anchor one flank on the river and the other on the high ground near Cannae, making it impossible for the Carthaginian horse to envelop their line as they had at Trebia. So I hope that makes sense to the listeners. Right, that makes sense. If you
特征决定了康诺利认为战役发生的位置。其中第一个是一条非常蜿蜒的河流，名叫阿尔菲迪乌斯河（Alphidius），河道随时间发生了变化，但康诺利认为它距离一片山脊大约一英里半，坎尼就坐落在这一山脊上。因此，在丘陵和阿尔菲迪乌斯河之间有这样一片开阔地带，用赞同康诺利看法的戈德斯沃西的话来说，“这个位置的优势是显而易见的。罗马人能够将一翼锚定在河上，另一翼锚定在坎尼附近的高地上，这使得迦太基骑兵不可能像在特雷比亚那样包围他们的阵线。”我希望听众能听懂。好的，这说得通。如果你
think the Romans come out and on their left flank, you have a ridge of hills, and on their right flank, you have a river. And this means that it's harder for the Carthaginians to outflank them with their cavalry. Yeah, so they're stretched across the terrain and they can't possibly be encircled. So there's a further advantage, which is that they're not staring into the sun because they're essentially facing kind of roughly southwards. There is one issue, which is that the wind is whipping up the dust. It's kind of late July in southern Italy, so there's quite a lot of dust and kind of blowing it into their faces.
认为罗马人出击，在他们的左翼，你有一座山脊，在他们的右翼，你有一条河。这意味着迦太基人用他们的骑兵包抄他们会变得更加困难。是的，所以他们横跨地形展开，绝无被合围的可能。所以还有一个额外的好处，那就是他们不会直视太阳，因为他们基本上大致朝南面对着敌人。有一个问题，那就是风卷起了尘土。这是南方意大利的七月下旬，所以有很多尘土，并且把它吹到他们的脸上。
But I think Varro clearly feels that the advantage of the position outweighs that. So his dispositions, infantry in the middle as ever, Roman cavalry on his right wing, His dispositions, infantry in the middle, as ever, Roman cavalry on his right wing, so that's next to the Arphidius, next to the river, and then the allied cavalry is on the left wing, which is next to the ridge of hills. And their role is purely defensive. You know, they're always going to be outnumbered and out fought by the Carthaginian horse. Their role is essentially to ensure that the line of infantry can't be attacked on the flanks. And this is really, really important because the goal has to be that the infantry defeats the Carthaginian infantry before the Roman and Italian cavalry can be chased off. And it's the measure of
但我认为瓦罗显然觉得这个位置的优势超过了这一劣势。所以他的部署是：步兵居中，一如既往；罗马骑兵在他的右翼，他的部署是：步兵居中，一如既往；罗马骑兵在他的右翼，也就是靠近阿尔菲迪乌斯河，靠近河流的地方；然后盟军骑兵在左翼，靠近山脊。他们的角色纯粹是防御性的。你知道的，他们在数量上总是会被迦太基骑兵压倒和击败。他们的角色基本上是确保步兵阵线不会在侧翼遭到攻击。这真的非常非常重要，因为目标必须是让步兵在罗马和意大利骑兵被赶跑之前击败迦太基步兵。这就是
how important this is that Varro himself takes up command of the allied cavalry and Paulus leads the Roman cavalry. So very, very important. But obviously it's the infantry that the Romans are pinning their hopes on. And so we should probably just describe, you know, what they look like, how they're lined up, what kind of how they're armed, that kind of thing, because these are not legions, not Roman soldiers of the kind that most people will be familiar with from gladiator or whatever. Right. This is from a kind of earlier period. And essentially the Roman infantry is lined up in four distinct ranks. So the first line consists of very lightly armed skirmishers who are called velites and Polybius specifies that these are the youngest and
Varro亲自去指挥同盟骑兵，Paulus指挥罗马骑兵，这一点是多么重要。真的是非常非常重要。但显然，罗马人把所有的希望都寄托在步兵身上。所以我们或许应该描述一下，你知道的，他们的外貌、阵型、装备等等，因为这些不是军团，不是大多数人通过《角斗士》或其他作品所熟知的古罗马士兵。没错。这是来自一个更早时期的军队。基本上，罗马步兵排成四个不同的横列。所以第一列是由装备非常轻便的散兵组成，他们被称为轻步兵（velites），波利比乌斯明确指出，这些人是最年轻的
the poorest. He gives a kind of very detailed account of how the Romans fought in battles and very gruevally, they would often wear wolf skin. You have your little spears and you have your wolf skin and you form a screen in front of the main block of the heavy infantry and they form three lines. So the first line is a group called Hastati. These are men in their late teens, early twenties. So they're young, they're full of vigor, but they're not as experienced as the next line of heavy infantry who are called the principes,
也是最贫穷的。他非常详细地描述了罗马人如何在战斗中作战，而且非常可怕的是，他们经常身穿狼皮。你带着你的小长矛和狼皮，在重步兵主力部队前方形成一道屏障，而重步兵则排成三列。所以第一列是一个被称为“青年兵”（Hastati）的群体。这些人处于十几岁到二十出头的年纪。所以他们很年轻，精力充沛，但他们不像下一列重步兵那样经验丰富，后者被称为“壮年兵”（principes）
so the chief men. These are guys who are in the prime of life. They're very fit, they're very strong, but they're also experienced. And then at the back you have a line called the triarii who are the veterans. Now how these heavy infantry armed is quite important for understanding the battle to get a sense of this. All the heavy infantry have very heavy kind of large oblong shields which are held up with the left arm. So that's quite a strain on the arm over the course of a long day. They might have a kind of small oblong plate on their chest, the pectorale, or if they can afford it, chainmail.
也就是主力骨干。这些人正值壮年。他们身体非常健康，非常强壮，但也很有经验。再往后，你有一列被称为“老兵”（triarii）的部队，他们是资深老兵。现在，这些重步兵的装备对于理解这场战役、感受当时的场景相当重要。所有的重步兵都配备了一种非常沉重的大型长方形盾牌，用左臂托着。所以在漫长的一天里，这对手臂来说是个相当大的负担。他们的胸前可能配有一块小型的长方形金属护胸板（pectorale），或者如果他们买得起的话，会穿上锁子甲。
And they're armed with the Spanish stabbing sword. So the sword that opens up the guts of the person that you're fighting with, you know, if you can get a clear stab at him. So the front two ranks, so that's the hastati and the principes, they also have two javelins. And I'll just quote Goldsworthy on this because lots of people listening to this have a sense that these javelins, the pila, the legionaries throw them and they then have a kind of bendy head. It's meant to stick in the enemy's shield and the droops down. This is not true. I'll read Goldsworthy on how these javelins work.
他们配备了西班牙刺剑。也就是那种能刺入你交战对手内脏的剑，你知道的，如果你能准确地刺中他的话。所以前两列，也就是青年兵和壮年兵，他们还配有两支标枪。我在这里引用戈尔兹沃西（Goldsworthy）的话，因为很多听众觉得这些标枪（pila）是军团士兵投掷出去的，并且带有某种可以弯曲的头部。它是用来卡在敌人的盾牌上然后下垂的。这不是真的。我来读一下戈尔兹沃西关于这些标枪是如何运作的。
All of the weapon's weight was concentrated behind the small tip, giving it great penetrative power. The length of the metal shank gave it the reach to punch through an enemy's shield and still go on to wound his body. But even if it failed to do so and merely stuck in the shield, it was very difficult to pull free and might force the man to discard his weighed down shield and fight unprotected. So basically you don't need the head to bend. I mean it's a massive problem if you've got a great spear stuck in your
武器的所有重量都集中在小巧的尖端后面，使其具有极强的穿透力。金属杆的长度使其具有足够的触及范围，能够刺穿敌人的盾牌并继续伤害其身体。但即使它未能做到这一点而仅仅卡在盾牌上，也很难被拔出，并可能迫使士兵丢弃沉重的盾牌，在毫无保护的情况下作战。所以基本上你不需要枪头弯曲。我的意思是，如果你的盾牌上卡着一支巨大的长矛，你不得不把它扔掉，然后对方可以用短剑（gladius）切开你的肚子，这就成了大麻烦。所以这是个非常糟糕的消息。第三列，也就是老兵（triarii），他们拥有非常长的刺矛，基本上作为预备队。
shield and you have to throw it away and then the guy can come up with his gladius and slice your stomach open. So very bad news. The third rank, so this is the veterans, the triarii, they have very long thrusting spears and they essentially are reserved. Should the first two ranks break then they will form a kind of porcupine, a defensive screen bristling with spears. I'm aware that that might all sound rather complicated, but the aim of it is to enable fresh units constantly to be filtered up to the front, so that if one line gets kind of annihilated or loses energy or whatever, then they can easily be replaced. And what gives the Roman line its flexibility is that there are kind of gaps built into the battle formations. The Roman lines are subdivided into units called maniples.
如果前两列被突破，他们将形成一种箭猪般的防御屏障，布满突出的长矛。我知道这听起来可能相当复杂，但其目的是让新鲜部队源源不断地输送到前线，这样如果某一条防线被歼灭或失去体力等等，他们就可以轻松得到替换。赋予罗马战线灵活性的是，其作战阵型中预留了各种间隙。罗马战线被细分为被称为“中队”（maniples）的单位。
And if people think of maybe a checkerboard or on a die a five, just lots and lots of those kind of fives that you get on on dice all in a row You have a manapal then you have a gap equivalent in length to the length of a manapal Then you have another manapal and then you have another row behind it But the manapal is behind it is filling in the gap But essentially it means that you can constantly thread people through the gaps and move people up to fill Gaps can I the depth of the manapoles, it's on a stupefying scale. So it's perhaps five or six men across. And then you think if you're standing in that
如果你想到也许是一个棋盘，或者骰子上的五点，就是排成一行的那些许许多多骰子上的五点。你有一个中队，然后是一个长度相当于一个中队的间隙，然后你又有另一个中队，然后后面还有一行，但后面的中队填补了间隙。但基本上这意味着你可以不断地把人穿过间隙输送过去，并移动人员来填补间隙。关于中队的纵深，它的规模大得惊人。可能横向有五到六个人。然后你想想，如果你站在那个
line, then next to you, there's a gap that's equivalent to five or six men, and then another five or six men, and then another gap, and then another five or six men, and then another gap. And then standing behind you, you have maybe it's maybe 30 deep. Procy. So when you put all the manapols together, the battle line is maybe 70 ranks deep. So completely terrifying for the enemy. I mean to be up against the line a mile and a half long that is that deep. But there's also an additional advantage from the Roman point of view, which is bear in mind how raw many of the Roman recruits are. If you have lines that are that deep and you put your best,
队列里，你旁边是一个相当于五六个人宽度的间隙，然后又是五六个人，然后又是一个间隙，然后又是五六个人，然后又是一个间隙。而在你身后，可能有30人那么深。天哪。所以当你把所有的中队组合在一起时，战线可能纵深达75列。对敌人来说完全是极其恐怖的。我是说，面对一条长达一英里半且纵深如此之大的战线。但从罗马人的角度来看，还有一个额外的优势，那就是记住罗马新兵中有多少人是缺乏经验的。如果你的阵线有这么深，并且你把最好、
most seasoned men in the front and the others at the rear, it's very difficult for raw, nervous recruits who might want to run away to do that because you're surrounded by people, there's no way you can escape. And so essentially, it's a way of kind of getting over the fact that perhaps these aren't the best trained troops that you could possibly have. So from your description, it sounds like an extremely meticulously devised, well ordered, formidable military machine. But is there an argument that the sheer size and complexity of this system means that it's frankly a bit lumbering and a bit over complicated and that Hannibal can actually exploit this?
最有经验的人放在最前面，其他人放在后方，那么对于那些可能想要逃跑的、紧张的新兵来说，要做到这一点是非常困难的，因为你周围都是人，你根本无法逃脱。所以从根本上讲，这是一种克服这样一个事实的方法：这些人可能不是你能拥有的训练有素的最佳部队。那么从你的描述来看，这听起来像是一个极其缜密、井然有序、令人敬畏的军事机器。但有没有这样一种论点，即这个系统庞大的规模和复杂性意味着它坦率地说有点笨拙、过于复杂，而汉尼拔实际上可以利用这一点？
I think that you have seized on the weakness that Hannibal seizes on, Dominic. We're very similar people, to be fair. I think that's exactly the problem with it. The kind of the manipular system which normally enables a Roman battle line to be very flexible. These maniples are so deep that actually it's quite difficult and that there's a risk of them crunching up against one another in which case the flexibility would be completely lost. And I think Hannibal's aim is to try and apply pressure where it will force the sheer numbers of the Roman legions to come crunching into one another. And in which case,
我认为你抓住了汉尼拔所利用的弱点，多米尼克。说实话，我们是非常相似的人。我认为这正是它的问题所在。通常使罗马战线具有很大灵活性的中队制，这些中队太深了，以至于实际上相当困难，而且它们彼此发生碰撞的风险很高，在这种情况下，灵活性将完全丧失。我认为汉尼拔的目标是试图在能够迫使罗马军团庞大的人数彼此相撞的地方施加压力。在这种情况下，
its size rather than being an advantage then becomes a source of weakness. But it's a hugely difficult thing to pull off. So the Roman plan basically is just to kind of advance and steamroll of the enemy. Hannibal's dispositions are much more complicated. As usual, like the Romans have done, he stations his infantry in the centre and his cavalry on the wings. He has Mahabal who's in command of the Numidian light cavalry on the right wing, so he is facing the allied cavalry commanded by Varro. On the left wing, so facing Paulus and the Roman cavalry, he's put the Spanish and Gallic heavy cavalry under the command of another very seasoned officer called inevitably Hasdrubal. So this isn't Hasdrubal the handsome, it's
它的规模非但没有成为优势，反而成了弱点的根源。但这是一件极其困难的事情。所以罗马人的计划基本上就是推进并像压路机一样碾压敌人。汉尼拔的部署要复杂得多。像往常一样，正如罗马人所做的那样，他将步兵部署在中央，骑兵部署在两翼。马哈巴尔（Mahabal）指挥右翼的努米底亚轻骑兵，所以他面对的是瓦罗（Varro）指挥的同盟骑兵。在左翼，也就是面对保卢斯（Paulus）和罗马骑兵的地方，他把西班牙和高卢重骑兵置于另一位经验非常丰富的军官的指挥之下，此人不可避免地叫作哈斯德鲁巴（Hasdrubal）。所以这不是那个美男子哈斯德鲁巴，
not Hasdrubal who's Hannibal's brother, it's another Hasdrubal. I just assume they're all called Hasdrubal, to be honest with you. Pretty much. And Hasdrubal is in command of about 7,000 men. So he is outnumbering the Roman cavalry under Paulus about three to one. So that is where the Carthaginians have the advantage. But obviously when it comes to infantry, that is a very different story because the Carthaginians there are massively outnumbered. However, fortunately for Hannibal, he has a plan, and it's a very cunning
不是汉尼拔的兄弟哈斯德鲁巴，是另一个哈斯德鲁巴。说实话，我只能假设他们都叫哈斯德鲁巴。差不多吧。哈斯德鲁巴指挥着大约7,000人。所以他在人数上以大约三比一的优势超过了保卢斯麾下的罗马骑兵。这就是迦太基人占据优势的地方。但显然，说到步兵，情况就大不相同了，因为那里的迦太基人在人数上处于极大的劣势。然而，幸运的是，汉尼拔有一个计划，而且是一个非常狡猾的
plan. So what he does is he draws up his Spanish and Gallic heavy infantry in a continuous line facing the Romans, so stretching for almost a mile and a half. And compared to the Romans, this Carthaginian battle line is very, very slender. Hannibal stations himself and Mago, his younger brother, in the center of the line, and he then leads the center of the line outwards towards the Roman lines. So the effect is to create a kind of crescent. The line starts to bulge outwards towards the Roman center. Hannibal's aim in doing this is to ensure that the Roman effort will be kind of focused on the middle of the plain. And the reason that he does this is because he knows that this is how the legions fight, that their aim is always to push through
计划。所以他做的是，他排开他的西班牙和高卢重步兵，组成一条面向罗马人的连续战线，绵延近一英里半。与罗马人相比，这条迦太基战线非常非常单薄。汉尼拔将自己和他的弟弟马戈（Mago）部署在战线中央，然后他带领战线中央向罗马军队的方向突前。因此，其效果是创造了一种新月形。战线开始向罗马军队的中央凸出。汉尼拔这样做的目的是确保罗马人的努力将集中在平原的中部。他这样做的原因是因为他知道这是军团作战的方式，他们的目标始终是冲破
the middle of their enemy's battle line. If they do that, then they will inevitably break through the Carthaginian line because it's so thin relative to the Romans. If they do that, then they will inevitably break through the Carthaginian line because it's so thin relative to the Romans. At the Trebia, the Romans had done that and Hannibal hadn't been able to stop them then from kind of marching off and doing what they wanted. But this time at Cannae, he has planned for this eventuality. So he is assuming that in the long run, the Roman line will break through the Spaniards and the Gauls and he has kept back the Libyans who are like a kind of phalanx, great long spears and equipped with Roman arms and Roman armour so they actually look quite like the legionaries and these are Hannibal's
敌人的战线中央。如果他们做到了这一点，他们将不可避免地突破迦太基战线，因为相对罗马人而言，迦太基战线太薄了。如果他们做到了这一点，他们将不可避免地突破迦太基战线，因为相对罗马人而言，迦太基战线太薄了。在特雷比亚（Trebia），罗马人就是这么做的，而汉尼拔当时没能阻止他们行军并做他们想做的事。但这一次在卡奈（Cannae），他已经为这种可能性做好了计划。所以他假设从长远来看，罗马战线将突破西班牙人和高卢人，而他留下了利比亚人，他们就像方阵一样，持有长长的矛，配备了罗马武器和罗马盔甲，所以他们看起来确实很像军团士兵，这些是汉尼拔
best, most disciplined troops and he has stationed them behind the front line and at an angle to it. So that if you imagine the Romans break through the line of the Spaniards and Gauls, the Libyans are like a pair of pincers ready to close in. So the Romans will think that they've broken through, they go rushing forwards, the Libyans will close in and capture them on their flanks. I mean, that is a difficult maneuver to pull off, but obviously if it does work, then potentially it's going to be very, very devastating in its effect. So just to try and get our heads around this, what effectively he's doing, he's not exactly sacrificing his front line, but he's assuming that his front line will break, the Romans
最好、纪律最严明的部队，他将他们部署在第一线后面并与之成一定角度。因此，如果你想象罗马人突破了西班牙人和高卢人的防线，利比亚人就像一把准备合拢的钳子。所以罗马人会以为他们已经突破了防线，他们向前冲去，而利比亚人会合拢并在他们的侧翼包抄他们。我的意思是，这是一个很难完成的机动动作，但显然如果它真的成功了，那么它的效果可能会非常非常毁灭性。为了让我们理解这一点，他实际上在做的，他并不是真的在牺牲他的第一线，而是假设他的第一线会被突破，罗马人
will break through, and his whole plan is that the Romans will break through and then he's got these Libyans behind who will pour into the Roman flanks. Like the jaws of a mouth with sharp teeth. The downside is you don't want to be the people in the front line. Right. Because he's basically decided you're expendable. Yeah, but Hannibal has placed himself there. But he's assuming that he will be, what, the Romans will just rush past him or that he will fall back. He's again backing himself, which is what he always does, that he will be able to inspire the men who
会突破防线，他的整个计划是罗马人突破防线，然后他身后有这些利比亚人会倾巢而出冲向罗马人的侧翼。就像一张长着利齿的嘴的上下颚。缺点是你不希望成为第一线的人。没错。因为他基本上决定了你是炮灰。是的，但汉尼拔自己就站在那里。但他假设他会成为，什么，罗马人会直接冲过他或者他会后撤。他再次将赌注押在自己身上，这也是他一贯的做法，他能够激励那些
are very, very loyal to him in the front row to fight as hard as possible. But it's accepted that at some point it will break. And then he has to hope that the Libyans will be able to play the role that he's assigned them. It's a dangerous, complicated plan, but it is a plan. And of course the other factor is that if the Libyans are able to seal the broken line and the front, you also have the cavalry in the rear who can then come up if they've swept away the Roman and Italian cavalry.
对他是如此忠诚的第一排士兵尽最大努力去战斗。但大家默认某个时刻防线会被突破。然后他必须希望利比亚人能够扮演他分配给他们的角色。这是一个危险、复杂的计划，但它确实是一个计划。当然另一个因素是，如果利比亚人能够封锁被突破的防线和正面，你的后方还有骑兵，如果在他们扫除了罗马和意大利骑兵之后，他们可以
They can then come galloping around and crash into the rear of the Roman army, and then you will have the whole army surrounded. And this has always been kind of Hannibal's dream. This is what he wants and he will have his battle of annihilation. But as I say, it's a complicated plan. So let's see what happens and see how it works out. So the battle lines are drawn up. And I think there's always this sense of nervous anticipation before it happens. There's lots of maneuvering, there's kind of blasting of trumpets. And then you just wait and you can imagine, you know, it's getting hotter.
随后策马赶来，猛烈撞击罗马军队的后方，然后你就会将整支军队包围。这一直是汉尼拔的梦想。这就是他想要的，他将迎来他的歼灭战。但正如我所说，这是一个复杂的计划。所以让我们看看会发生什么，看看结果如何。因此，战线已经拉开。我想在这一切发生之前总有一种紧张期待的感觉。有大量的调动，吹响了号角声。然后你只需等待，你可以想象，你知道的，天气越来越热。
The sun is rising in the sky. The shields are starting to feel heavier on the arm. Sweat around, you know, as you hold your spears or whatever. I mean, very, very nerve wracking because it's nerve wracking. Ultimately, the time comes where people think, oh, hang this, let's get on with it. And the people who begin are the skirmishers. The Carthaginians again are outnumbered, but they are much, much more proficient than the Velites, the Roman skirmishers in their wolf clothes and stuff. And in particular,
太阳在天空中升升起。盾牌在手臂上开始感觉越来越重。当你握着长矛或其他东西时，周围全是汗水。我的意思是，非常非常紧张，因为这令人揪心。最终，到了人们觉得“哦，去他的，我们上吧”的时刻。最先开始的是散兵。迦太基人再次在人数上处于劣势，但他们比身穿狼皮等装备的罗马散兵瓦莱特（Velites）要精干得多、厉害得多。特别是，
the Balearic slingers, my favorite, are absolutely lethal. So they have a much longer range than the velites do with their little spears. They're very accurate. The slingshot is coming out, you know, you've got all this dust blowing up, very difficult to see the slingshot as it comes. If it hits you on the helmet, it is possible to kind of knock you out. And so understandably, the Roman infantry decide, well, we don't want this, you know, get rid of the velites. The velites withdraw. This is Daly's theory, I think he's right. They go right the way back behind the full line of the Roman heavy infantry. And this then means that the front line of the Roman heavy infantry are in a position to advance. This is what's been going on in
巴利阿里投石手（我最喜欢的）是绝对致命的。所以他们的射程比带着小长矛的轻步兵要远得多。他们非常准确。投石索飞了出来，你知道的，到处都是扬起的尘土，投石索飞来时很难看清。如果它击中了你的头盔，是有可能把你击晕的。因此，可以理解的是，罗马步兵决定，好吧，我们不想要这个，你知道的，把轻步兵撤下来。轻步兵撤退了。这是戴利（Daly）的理论，我认为他是对的。他们一直退到罗马重步兵完整战线的后方。这意味着罗马重步兵的第一线处于可以推进的位置。这就是
the opening maneuvers of the battle. Meanwhile, you've got the cavalry and on the banks of the Ophidius, the river, which is where Hastribal's Spanish and Gallic heavy cavalry are facing Paulus's Roman horse, it is all kicking off. And the Carthaginians, even as the skirmishers are still doing their stuff with their javelins and their slingshot and stuff, the Carthaginian cavalry are herring towards the Romans. They just pile into Paulus and his men, and there's a story in Plutarch that Paulus is wounded, that he has to dismount, that all his officers around him think, oh well he's doing it, we better do it, they dismount, and then the whole
战役开局机动时正在发生的事情。与此同时，你有了骑兵，在奥菲迪乌斯河（Ophidius）河畔，哈斯德鲁巴的西班牙和高卢重骑兵正面对着保卢斯的罗马骑马部队，战斗全面爆发了。当散兵们还在用他们的标枪和投石索大显身手时，迦太基骑兵正朝着罗马人疾驰而去。他们径直冲向保卢斯和他的手下，普鲁塔克（Plutarch）有这样一个故事：保卢斯受伤了，他不得不下马，他周围的所有军官都想，好吧，既然他都下马了，我们最好也下马，他们下了马，然后整个
Roman force dismounts, and it may be that this is a kind of an attempt by the Romans to explain why it is that the Roman horse put up such a weak show. Anyway, they are absolutely swept away. They have not managed to put up a fight at all. Paulus is able to clamber his way into the main body of the infantry. So he is able to survive this route. But I mean, it's very poor on the part of the Roman horse and brilliant for Hasdrubal and his men who have swept the Roman flank clear and Hasdrubal does not do a Prince Rupert. So he doesn't go hering off after the Roman cavalry. He wheels round and he looks at the state of battle and what he decides to do we will come to in due course because meanwhile in the main field of battle where the two
罗马军队都下了马，这可能是罗马人试图解释为什么罗马骑兵表现如此软弱的一种尝试。无论如何，他们被彻底横扫了。他们根本没能组织起任何抵抗。保卢斯得以爬进步兵主力部队。所以他得以在这场溃败中幸存。但我的意思是，罗马骑兵的表现非常糟糕，而对于哈斯德鲁巴和他的手下来说则是绝妙的，他们扫清了罗马人的侧翼，而且哈斯德鲁巴没有表现得像鲁珀特亲王（Prince Rupert）。所以他没有盲目追击罗马骑兵。他掉转马头，观察着战局，并决定做些什么，我们将在适当时机谈到这一点，与此同时，在两支宏大的步兵方阵互相面对的主战场上，
great blocks of infantry are facing one another, clash point is happening. So what's going on with the infantry? So the Roman young men, but probably the best, the most seasoned, the most proficient in fighting have been stationed in the front rank. They are smashing their weapons on their wooden shields, kind of terrifying counterpart to this great nodding crests that they have on their helmets. Their armor is brilliantly polished and on the other side you have the Spaniards and the Gauls, they are holding
交战点正在发生。那么步兵那边发生了什么？所以罗马的年轻人，但很可能是最优秀、最有经验、作战最熟练的人被部署在第一列。他们用武器猛烈敲击着木质盾牌，与他们头盔上高耸晃动的羽饰形成了恐怖的呼应。他们的盔甲被打磨得闪闪发光，而在另一边是西班牙人和高卢人，他们坚守
their position, remember the front of the bulge, very, very close to the Roman line. They're raising their own war cries, the Gallic war cries in particular notorious. They also have their, you know, these trumpets, the carnics, terrifying din. And this is an age where people generally are not used to loud noise in the way that we are in the 21st century. So the din of the, you know, is overwhelming. And so it's not surprising that the moment that the skirmishes are out of the way, the Romans charge. They're thinking, you know, let's get this over and done with. The sooner this is done, the better for all concerned. So the Hestarte, they advance the front ranks, probably the front two or three, because, you know, they don't want to start hitting their own men with javelins. They hurl them. The
阵位，记住凸出部的最前端，距离罗马战线非常非常近。他们高呼着自己的战吼，尤其是高卢人的战吼臭名昭著。他们还有他们的，你知道的，这些战号（carnics），发出可怕的喧嚣。这是一个人们通常不像我们21世纪这样习惯巨响的时代。所以这种噪音，你知道的，是压倒性的。因此，一旦散兵离开，罗马人发起冲锋也就不足为奇了。他们心想，你知道的，让我们速战速决吧。这事越早结束，对所有人越好。所以青年兵（Hestarte）推进了前几列，大概是最前两三列，因为，你知道的，他们不想用标枪误伤自己人。他们投掷了标枪。
effect of this is less effective than normal, because effectively they, you know, because of the bulge of the Carthaginian line, they can't actually reach most of the Carthaginian front line with their spears. And then they charge and the hope is that they will be able to break the enemy so that they just go running away and then the killing can start. But this doesn't happen. The Spaniards and Gauls hold their positions, partly because they're very seasoned veterans by this point, partly because Hannibal and Mago is there with them in the front rank, and partly because they just hate the Romans, and probably they trust in Hannibal that his
这产生的效果比平时要差，因为实际上他们，你知道的，由于迦太基战线的凸出，他们实际上无法用长矛够到大多数迦太基前线士兵。然后他们发起冲锋，希望能够击溃敌人，让他们四散奔逃，这样杀戮就可以开始了。但这并没有发生。西班牙人和高卢人坚守阵地，部分原因是因为他们此时已经是经验丰富的老兵，部分原因是因为汉尼拔和马戈与他们一起在前线，部分原因是因为他们痛恨罗马人，并且可能他们相信汉尼拔的
strategy is going to work and that they're going to have their vengeance. They understand also how important a role that they have, how important it is that they maintain their position for as long as they possibly can. And Daly in his book explains why. It was absolutely necessary for the peculiar crescent formation to be maintained so that the thin horns of the crescent,
战略会奏效，他们将报仇雪恨。他们也理解自己扮演的角色有多么重要，尽可能长时间地保持阵位是多么重要。戴利在他的书中解释了原因。绝对有必要保持独特的新月形阵型，以便新月形纤细的犄角，
so that's the two flanks, would be kept out of the fighting for as long as possible. Because if the troops there broke early in the battle, the entire Carthaginian plan would collapse. So in other words, it's vital for Hannibal that the Roman forces are funneled into the center so that they can go into the kind of the mouth of these two Libyan jaws that are waiting to snap shut on them. It's a very kind of grinding clash. It's kind of man on man. And effectively the whole line is this kind of series of duels between Gauls and Spaniards against Romans. The Romans and
也就是两个侧翼，能够尽可能长时间地远离战斗。因为如果那里的部队在战斗初期崩溃，整个迦太基计划就会瓦解。换句话说，对汉尼拔来说至关重要的是，罗马军队被汇集到中央，这样他们就能走进这两扇等待猛然合拢的利比亚巨钳的口中。这是一场非常残酷的绞杀。这是一种人对人的较量。实际上整条战线就是高卢人和西班牙人对阵罗马人的一系列决斗。罗马人和
the Spaniards are both armed with stabbing swords, so they're both aiming, you know, they're aiming at the abdomen. The Gauls have slashing swords, so they're aiming at the shoulders. And most of the the wounds because both sides have shields are probably to parts of the body that aren't protected by either the shield or by armor so that's heads, legs, sword arms. If you get too many wounds on your leg or your arm or to your head then obviously you start to weaken you might lose your balance, your ability to continue fighting, you might fall to the ground and the moment you fall to the ground, that's it. You're dead. You know, there's going to be a blow to your head.
西班牙人都装备了刺剑，所以他们的目标都是，你知道的，他们的目标是腹部。高卢人有砍剑，所以他们的目标是肩膀。由于双方都有盾牌，大多数伤口可能都在身体未被盾牌或盔甲保护的部位，比如头部、腿部、挥剑的手臂。如果你的腿、手臂或头部受到太多创伤，显然你就会开始虚弱，你可能会失去平衡，失去继续战斗的能力，你可能会倒在地上，而一旦你倒在地上，那就完了。你死定了。你知道的，你的头部会遭到致命一击。
Or just trampled underfoot. Trampled underfoot. And of course, the more bodies are trampled underfoot, the more they rise, the more slippery the ground becomes because blood is starting to spill out and you know, moisten the dust that is everywhere. And you have exhaustion as well because the sun is rising higher and higher in the sky. You've got the dust blowing in. And the estimate is that men can't really fight in this way for more than 15 minutes at a stretch.
或者直接被踩在脚下。被踩在脚下。当然，被踩在脚下的尸体越多，他们堆积起来，地面就会变得越滑，因为鲜血开始流出，弄湿了到处都是的尘土。你还要应对精疲力竭，因为太阳在天空中越升越高。尘土不断吹进来。据估计，人在这种状态下连续作战的时间实在无法超过15分钟。
So the lines, you wouldn't think of it, the lines are kind of engaging, then withdrawing, engaging, then withdrawing. Kind of almost the rhythm of a really brutal sporting encounter, I guess. Yeah. You know, very intense moments of engagement and then the players withdraw and kind of
所以战线，你可能不会这么想，战线交锋然后撤回，交锋然后撤回。几乎就像是一场极其残暴的体育比赛的节奏，我想是的。是的，你知道的，极其激烈的交战时刻，然后选手们退回并
draw their breath and then back in again and just physically relentless and demanding. But the advantage of the Roman manipular system is that people, you know, men who just become too tired or too wounded can be withdrawn and they can funnel more people Forward so there is this kind of relentless sense of fresh men coming to the front line And so it's unsurprising that as the fighting goes on although the Gauls and Spaniards fight with the utmost ferocity and implacability the Roman weight of numbers does start to tell and As the Roman front line grinds forward the crescent and implacability. The Roman weight of numbers does start to tell and as the Roman front line grinds forward the crescent that the Gauls and the Spaniards
喘口气，然后再次投入战斗，从体力上讲这是无情且苛刻的。但罗马中队制的优势在于，人们，你知道的，那些变得太累或受伤太重的士兵可以撤下来，他们可以输送更多的人上前线，所以有一种新鲜血液源源不断涌向最前线的无情感觉。因此，随着战斗的进行，尽管高卢人和西班牙人和高卢人以极其凶猛和不可妥协的态度战斗，罗马人庞大的人数优势还是开始显现出来，随着罗马第一线向前推进，高卢人和西班牙人
have formed starts to flatten and then to buckle and to be pushed backwards and the Romans in the center give a great cheer, they consent victory, they push forwards, space opens up behind them as they do so, more troops come filling in to fill the gap, the order of the manaples starts to be lost, it's a great excited crush because everyone wants to share in the victory, cries of joy, of triumph kind of rippling through the entire Roman battle line, the feeling is absolutely that the battle is won, but of course Hannibal still has his two deadly cards to play. And as the Gauls and Spaniards retreat, space has opened up for the Libyans who are hitherto
组成的新月形阵线开始变平，接着弯曲并被向后推去，中央的罗马人发出巨大的欢呼，他们预感到胜利，他们向前冲去，随着他们这样做，身后的空间打开了，更多的军队涌来填补空隙，中队的秩序开始丧失，这是一场极度兴奋的人潮拥挤，因为每个人都想分享胜利的果实，喜悦和胜利的欢呼声在整个罗马战线中此起彼伏，这种感觉绝对是胜券在握，但当然汉尼拔还有两张致命的王牌要打。随着高卢人和西班牙人撤退，原本一直作为预备队的利比亚人终于有了空间，得以猛烈撞击前进中的罗马人的侧翼。
been held in reserve to crash into the flanks of the advancing Romans. And it happens exactly as Hannibal has planned. I mean, it couldn't go better because by now the Romans are so tightly packed that they haven't got any opportunity to maneuver. And in fact, it couldn't go better because by now the Romans are so tightly packed that they haven't got any opportunity to maneuver and in fact, it's quite difficult for them even to kind of, you know, raise their sword arms. And you just have this kind of great scrum of men who are being slowly crushed together by the Libyan phalanxes to their left and to their right. And ahead of them, the Gauls and the Spaniards who had been retreating, you know, they get a second win, they sense that the balance of the battle has changed, they turn around, they block the Roman
事情正如汉尼拔所计划的那样发生了。我的意思是，事情不可能进展得更顺利了，因为此时罗马人挤得太紧了，根本没有任何机动空间。事实上，事情不可能进展得更顺利了，因为此时罗马人挤得太紧了，根本没有任何机动空间，甚至连举起握剑的手臂都变得相当困难。你只能看到一大群人被左侧和右侧的利比亚方阵慢慢挤压在一起。而在他们前方，一直在撤退的高卢和西班牙人，你知道的，他们恢复了体力，感觉到战局的天平已经倾斜，他们转过身来，挡住了罗马人的
advance, and the absolute horror for the Romans is that one minute they think they're winning, the battle is won, and then suddenly they find themselves surrounded on three sides by people who are not fleeing at all. And the Libyans are completely fresh. And more than that, they actually look like Romans, so it must have come as a massive surprise for the Romans to suddenly find them crashing into them. So a horrible situation. And the Romans didn't anticipate this at all. I mean, you would think that practiced commanders would see the crescent shape and they would think, well, the one thing we don't want to happen is for our boys to be enveloped by the flanks of this crescent.
推进，对罗马人来说绝对的恐怖在于，前一分钟他们还觉得自己要赢了，战斗已经胜利了，然后突然发现自己被三面没有丝毫逃跑迹象的人群包围了。而且利比亚人完全是生力军。不仅如此，他们看起来实际上就像罗马人，所以突然发现他们猛烈冲撞过来，这一定给罗马人带来了巨大的震惊。所以这是一个可怕的局面。而罗马人对此毫无预料。我的意思是，你会认为经验丰富的指挥官会看到新月形阵型，然后他们会认为，我们最不想发生的事情就是我们的士兵被这个新月形的侧翼包围。
And yet they've walked straight into it. Because they're trusting their weight of numbers, because that's how they fight, because they're not geniuses like Hannibal, because the men that they have are not seasoned. They can't kind of think on their feet. They're not practiced at maneuvering. And that of course is the mark of Hannibal's genius is that he, you know, he's exploiting all of that and he's like a judo thrower turning his enemy's strength into a weakness.
然而他们却直直地走了进去。因为他们笃信自己庞大的人数，因为他们就是这样战斗的，因为他们不像汉尼拔那样是天才，因为他们手下的士兵没有经过充分的历练。他们不能临场应变。他们不习惯机动。当然，这就是汉尼拔天才的标志，他，你知道的，在利用这一切，他就像一个柔道高手，将敌人的力量转化为弱点。
And you said he had two cards to play. He's played one, which was the Libyans. Now the second, of course, you mentioned it before Hasdrubal and the heavy cavalry, as you said, they haven't gone shooting off. They now return to the fray, don't they? People may remember that they've swept away Paulus who has gone to join the main body of the infantry. The rest of the Roman cavalry have been swept away from the battlefield. So what Hasdrubal does is he then turns around the length of the Roman infantry to go to the other wing where the Numidians under Mahabal have been having a standoff with the Italians
你刚才说他有两张牌要打。他已经打出了一张，那就是利比亚人。现在第二张，当然，你之前提到过，正如你所说，哈斯德鲁巴和重骑兵并没有盲目冲开。他们现在重返战场了，对吧？人们可能还记得，他们横扫了前往加入步兵主力部队的保卢斯。其余的罗马骑兵已经被赶出战场。所以哈斯德鲁巴所做的是，他随后沿着罗马步兵的侧翼掉转方向，前往另一个侧翼，在那里，马哈巴尔麾下的努米底亚人一直与瓦罗率领的意大利人
under Varro because the Numidians are light, they don't want to engage with the Italian cavalry. But now suddenly Hasdrubal and his heavy cavalry come sweeping up. The Italians are swept away again. Varro is swept away with them, so he's gone from the scene of the battle. He survives, but he's now gone. This means that Hasdrupal and his heavy cavalry can now crash into the rear of the Roman infantry. And the likelihood is the infantry in the rear of the Roman battle line are not the seasoned veterans with their long spears who could have formed a phalanx and kept the cavalry away, but the velites, the skirmishers with their wolf skins, and there is nothing that they can do against
处于对峙状态，因为努米底亚人是轻骑兵，他们不想与意大利骑兵交战。但现在突然间，哈斯德鲁巴和他的重骑兵席卷而来。意大利人再次被横扫。瓦罗也随之被横扫，所以他退出了战场。他虽然活了下来，但现在已经不在战场上了。这意味着哈斯德鲁巴和他的重骑兵现在可以猛烈撞击罗马步兵的后方。而很可能的是，罗马战线后方的步兵不是那些能够组成方阵并阻挡骑兵的持有长矛的资深老兵，而是那些身披狼皮的轻步兵，面对
heavy cavalry. So in that description by Livy, you read of the battlefield the day after the battle, there was an account of men lying there whose tendons had been sliced and who can't move. And this I think is what Hasdrubal's cavalry are doing. As they gallop in, if they can't kill someone, they just slice the tendons and leave them there to exsanguinate the blood to spill out. And then they start crashing forwards and the press of Romans trying to withdraw pushes back in and the whole Roman army now is surrounded. You've got the Gauls and the Spaniards on the front. You've got the Libyans on the flanks. You've got Hasdrubal's cavalry in the rear. The process of annihilation is now set in train and it
重骑兵，他们无能为力。所以在李维（Livy）的描述中，你读到了战后次日的战场，有记载称人们躺在那里，他们的脚筋被割断了，无法动弹。我想这就是哈斯德鲁巴的骑兵们在做的事情。当他们策马冲入时，如果他们杀不死某人，他们就会割断对方的脚筋，然后留他们在那里流尽鲜血。接着他们开始向前猛冲，试图撤退的罗马人的人潮被向后推挤，整个罗马军队现在被包围了。正面有高卢人和西班牙人。侧翼有利比亚人。后方有哈斯德鲁巴的骑兵。歼灭的过程现在已经开始，
takes Hannibal's men many hours. And it must have been a hideous experience for everyone. I mean, completely exhausting, even for Annabelle's men. Their shields are heavy, their sword arms are starting to ache, they're drenched in sweat, lots of them are wounded. And I imagine that as the battle goes on, so the pauses between the bouts of combat go longer and longer. And for the Romans trapped inside, I mean, this just must have been... And we're talking about tens of thousands of men. Tens of thousands. So some of them managed to escape. You know, there were kind of gaps in the Carthaginian line they can get out. Some of the Italian allies surrender and that's
这花了他的人民好几个小时。对每个人来说，这一定是一次可怕的经历。我的意思是，筋疲力尽，即使对汉尼拔的手下也是如此。他们的盾牌很重，挥剑的手臂开始酸痛，他们浑身湿透了汗水，许多人受了伤。我想随着战斗的进行，两次交锋之间的间歇变得越来越长。对于被困在里面的罗马人来说，我的意思是，这简直……而且我们谈论的是成千上万的人。成千上万。所以他们当中有些人设法逃脱了。你知道的，迦太基战线上有一些缺口他们可以逃出去。一些意大利盟友投降了，这没
fine. You know, Hannibal's policy is absolutely to accept their surrender. But the Romans though, you know, they, most of them stand their ground. A refusal to submit is the essence of what being a Roman is. It's the quality that's most admired in the Republic. And I think it's hard to overemphasize the horror of their fate, the physical crush, the panic, and the certainty of approaching death. Because if you're in the center of this kind of great crush of men, imagine, you
问题。你知道的，汉尼拔的政策绝对是接受他们的投降。但罗马人呢，你知道的，他们大多数人坚守阵地。拒绝屈服是身为罗马人的核心本质。这是共和国中最受推崇的品质。而且我认为怎么强调他们命运的恐怖、肉体的挤压、恐慌以及逼近的死亡的确定性都不为过。因为如果你处于这种巨大的人群挤压中央，想象一下，
don't really know what's happening, and then the news comes to you about what's happened. You're stuck there waiting for the Carthaginian swords and spears to reach you. I mean, just hideous. People start to void their bowels to urinate with terror, to vomit. Piles of corpses are starting to rise. The sun is high in the sky. So they're starting to smell it's drifting across the battlefield is high in the sky so they're starting to smell, it's drifting across the battlefield, death from the air, slingshot is starting to rain down again, you've still got this blinding dust and blood just everywhere drenching it. I mean it's like wading through a sea of blood and viscera and I think the trauma of it is most grotesquely and unsettlingly
你并不知道发生了什么，然后关于发生的事情的消息传到了你这里。你被困在那里，等待着迦太基的剑和长矛够到你。我的意思是，简直太可怕了。人们开始因为恐惧而大小便失禁、呕吐。尸体堆开始垒起来。太阳高悬在天空中。所以他们开始闻到气味，这气味在战场上飘荡，烈日高悬，所以他们开始闻到气味，它在战场上飘荡，从空中袭来的死亡，投石索开始再次像雨点般落下，你仍然有这令人盲目的尘土和到处浸透的鲜血。我的意思是，这就像是在血海和内脏中蹚行，我认为这种创伤最怪诞、最令人不安的
illustrated in that passage that you opened this episode with. People may remember that Livy reports how the day after the Carthaginians inspect the battlefield and they find among the Roman dead some with their heads buried in the ground. I mean, I can't believe that's true, but if it is, then it's either kind of suicide or an attempt to hide from the horrors of the battle and the fact that Livy records it, I mean it must have been a story that was current at the time and therefore surely reflective of the scale of the horror and by the end of the day, upwards of you know, I mean tens of thousands of Romans are dead. Yeah just looking at the estimates between 50 and 70,000 men probably were killed. I
体现，就在你开篇引入本集的那段文字中。人们可能还记得李维报道了迦太基人在战后次日视察战场时，发现在罗马死者中有人把头埋在泥土里。我的意思是，我不敢相信这是真的，但如果它是真的，那么这要么是一种自杀，要么是试图躲避战场的恐怖，而李维记录了这一点，我的意思是这一定是在当时流传的一个故事，因此无疑反映了恐怖的规模，到了那天结束时，多达，你知道的，成千上万的罗马人死亡。是的，只要看看估计数字，可能有5到7万人被杀。我的意思是，
mean, just absolutely massacred where they stood. And, you know, for Hannibal, this must be a victory beyond his wildest dreams. I mean, just a staggering success, a vindication of his tactics, of his approach. He has absolutely annihilated this Roman army and brought the Romans to their lowest ebb. I mean, I think you could say it's the most astonishing, the most remarkable victory that any general had ever won in history. And that is why it continues to be studied and admired by military strategists to this day. And you can't say that of any other ancient battle. It has a kind of perfection, a terrifying perfection about it. And yet he hasn't won the war because the question now is what will the Romans do? Will they sue for
简直是在他们站立的地方遭到大屠杀。而且，你知道的，对于汉尼拔来说，这一定是一场超越他最疯狂梦想的胜利。我的意思是，这简直是一场惊人的成功，是对他的战术和方法的证明。他彻底歼灭了这支罗马军队，把罗马人带到了他们的最低谷。我的意思是，我认为你可以说这是历史上任何将军取得的最惊人、最卓越的胜利。这就是为什么它至今仍被军事战略家研究和赞赏的原因。你不能对任何其他古代战役这样说。它有一种完美性，一种可怕的完美性。然而他还没有赢得战争，因为现在的问题是罗马人会怎么做？他们会求和吗？
peace? Where does he go from here? Does he march on Rome? Does he try to destroy the Republic? Or have the Romans got one more comeback left in them, Tom? Do you know, Dominic, we are going to leave that question as a cliffhanger. We are going to end our series on the rise of Hannibal at this point. Hannibal has attained the absolute pinnacle of everything he could have dreamed of. But as you say, there is still the fact that Rome is not yet defeated. Should Hannibal march on Rome? What's going to happen?
他从这里去哪里？他会进军罗马吗？他会试图摧毁共和国吗？还是罗马人还剩最后一次东山再起的机会，汤姆？你知道吗，多米尼克，我们将把这个问题作为一个悬念留下。我们将在此时结束关于汉尼拔崛起的系列节目。汉尼拔已经达到了他梦寐以求的一切的绝对巅峰。但正如你所说，罗马尚未被击败的事实依然存在。汉尼拔应该进军罗马吗？会发生什么？
And we will hopefully answer those questions with a third series, which will take the story forwards. And that series as well will end on a terrible note. We love a terrible note on the rest of history. We also like to torment and tantalise our listeners by leaving them hanging at the end of series. And that's what we've done. We've had season one, we've had season two, season three will be coming. Brilliant. So next week we will be back with
我们希望将在推动故事发展的第三季中回答这些问题。而且那一季也会以一个可怕的结局收场。我们喜欢“余烬历史”里的可怕结局。我们还喜欢通过在每季结束时悬念迭起，来折磨和挑逗我们的听众。这就是我们所做的。我们有了第一季，我们有了第二季，第三季即将到来。太棒了，所以下周我们将回归
something very different. We'll still be in Italy, but we will be in the golden age of Renaissance Florence for the story of the Medici. But Tom, thank you so much for that. A blood curdling tour de force, I think it's fair to say. And never has there been so much dust in a Restless History podcast? Dust and blood. Dust and blood. We love it. On that bombshell, thank you very much and goodbye everybody. Bye bye. Hi everybody, you're still here. Right at the end of the episode, I'm very impressed by your commitment. But listen, I have a question for you. I want to ask you something in confidence. Do you sometimes listen to the adverts on these episodes? And do you sometimes think, do you know what?
非常不同的事情。我们将继续留在意大利，但我们将处于文艺复兴时期佛罗伦萨的黄金时代，讲述美第奇家族的故事。汤姆，非常感谢你。我想说这是一次令人毛骨悚然的精彩表现。在《Restless History》播客中，从来没有出现过这么多的尘埃？尘埃与鲜血。尘埃与鲜血。我们太喜欢了。带着这个重磅炸弹，非常感谢大家，再见。拜拜。大家好，你们还在。在剧集的最后，我对你们的执着印象深刻。但是听着，我有一个问题想问你们。我想私下问你们一件事。你们有时会听这些剧集里的广告吗？你们有时会想，你知道吗？
I wish that the listeners to this podcast, I wish they were listening to an advert about my brand rather than the other stuff that Tom and Dominic are promoting on here. If you have thought that there is of course, any one way to find out what that would be like. You can disrupt the procession of adverts. You could be the next HSBC premiere or the many other tremendous companies that have advertised on the rest is history and you could put your brand in front of millions of like minded listeners by advertising on the rest is history and indeed the other shows on the Goalhanger Network. Now you may be thinking, I don't know what the Goalhanger Network is.
我希望这个播客的听众，我希望他们听的是关于我的品牌的广告，而不是汤姆和多米尼克在这里推广的其他东西。如果你这样想过，当然只有一个方法可以知道那会是什么样子。你可以打断广告的进程。你可以成为下一个汇丰卓越理财或在《The Rest is History》上广告过的许多其他了不起的公司之一，你可以通过在《The Rest is History》以及Goalhanger网络上的其他节目中投放广告，将你的品牌展示给数百万志同道合的听众。现在你可能会想，我不知道什么是Goalhanger网络。
Goalhanger are the company behind this very show. And if you are in the market to increase the value of your brand, Goalhanger would love to hear from you. You can register your interest, or indeed your company's interest, by going to Goalhanger.com right now. And that is Goal, G-O-A-L, hangar, H-A-N-G-E-R, dot com. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
Goalhanger就是制作这个节目的公司。如果你正打算提升你的品牌价值，Goalhanger非常希望听到你的声音。你可以立即访问Goalhanger.com来登记你或你公司的兴趣。那就是Goal，G-O-A-L，hangar，H-A-N-G-E-R，点com。本集还没有评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。